Nos piden que factoricemos por agrupación,
esta expresión que tenemos aquí,
5rs más 25r menos 3s menos 15.
Y lo primero que quiero que te des cuenta
es que tenemos 4 términos
y además no tenemos
un factor común de todos ellos,
por ejemplo estos 2 son divisibles entre 5
pero -3s no,
ésto es divisible entre "r",
éste es divisible entre "r",
pero estos dos no
5rs y -3s son divisibles entre "s"
pero los otros dos no
y por lo tanto,
no hay un factor común de todos.
Así que lo que voy a hacer
es factorizar por agrupación
y para factorizar por agrupación
lo que hay que fijarnos
es en los primeros dos términos
y ahí factorizar lo más que se pueda,
y después en los segundos 2 términos
y de ahí factorizar lo más que se pueda.
Así que vamos a hacerlo,
vamos a fijarnos primero en estos 2,
en 5rs más 25r,
y de aquí vamos a factorizar
lo más que se pueda,
y si te das cuenta,
estos 2 tienen quinta y además
tienen "r"
por lo tanto,
lo más que se puede factorizar estos 2
es 5r
así que déjenme escribirlo aquí abajo.
5r es lo más que se puede factorizar,
¿5r que multiplica a quién?
5rs entre 5r pues me dan "s"
y después tengo 25r entre 5r
esto me da 5
y tú lo puedes comprobar multiplicando
5r por "s" más 5
y tienes que llegar a 5rs más 25r,
5 por 5 es 25
y creo que hasta aquí vamos bien.
Después tengo 5r es mi factor común,
que multiplica a "s" más 5
pero ahora me voy a fijar
en los siguientes 2 términos,
en estos 2 y de aquí voy a factorizar
también lo más que se pueda
y seguramente te estás dando cuenta
que lo más que se puede factorizar es un 3,
un más 3 o un -3
sin embargo,
voy a usar el -3
para que adentro del paréntesis,
después de que realice la factorización
por el factor común,
me quede algo muy parecido a ese más 5
y para esto necesito que
adentro del paréntesis sean positivos
por lo tanto,
voy a factorizar en -3 y me queda,
-3s entre -3 me da "s"
y después -15 entre -3
menos entre menos nada más,
15 entre 3 es 5,
entonces me queda ese más 5,
y justo en este momento seguramente
hay algo que ya te está saltando a simple vista.
Aquí hay algo muy parecido
de estos dos paréntesis
pero, antes de eso lo que quiero que veas,
es que si tú tienes dudas
si has factorizado bien,
lo que puedes hacer
es distribuir ambos productos
para ver si llega a ser lo mismo,
si tú distribuyes el 5r y el -3
tendrás que llegar a la expresión
que tenemos aquí arriba,
pero bueno, lo que quiero que veas,
es que aquí hay algo muy parecido,
tenemos "s" más 5
como factor común,
"s" más 5,
es nuestro factor común.
porque en este momento es más 5,
está multiplicando tanto a 5r como -3,
aunque sea un binomio, es un binomio que se repite,
y que está multiplicando a su vez a 5r y a -3
por lo tanto qué te parece
si lo agarramos como factor común
y me queda "s" más 5
que multiplica a quién,
bueno,
en primer lugar va a multiplicar a 5r,
eso es lo que dice la parte de amarillo,
"s" más 5 multiplica a 5r,
pero por otra parte,
por la parte de morado,
"s" más 5 también multiplica a -3
por lo tanto me queda
"s" más 5,
que en primer lugar multiplica a 5r
y después multiplica -3
y ya está.
Ya tengo mi factorización por agrupación,
y para comprobarlo,
tú lo puedes ver de la siguiente manera.
Podremos multiplicar ese más 5
primero por 5r y después por -3
y llegaríamos a la expresión
que tenemos aquí arriba
y después podríamos multiplicar 5r por "s" más 5
y llegaríamos a esto que tenemos aquí
y -3 por "s" más 5
y llegaríamos a nuestros últimos 2 términos de morado.